i'll also confirm cabinet's decision to
propose some additional protections in
relation to large-scale live events and
indoor public places we judge these to
be necessary to further slow the spread
of the virus so that we can protect
health the national health service and
the economy as we work to complete
booster vaccinations and i'll set out
further support for the many businesses
affected by the advice we feel duty
bound to give in the interest of
protecting public health first though
today's statistics 5242
positive cases were reported yesterday
at 14.9 of tests carried out 515 people
are in hospital with covered one fewer
than yesterday 37 people are in
intensive care also won fewer than
yesterday and sadly a further nine
deaths have been reported taking the
total number of deaths under the daily
definition to
9790 and i want again to send my
condolences to everyone who has lost a
loved one
playing officer in last week's statement
i reported that casey's had increased by
25
in the preceding seven days and that we
would in all likelihood see a further
increase in infections as omicron became
the dominant strain circulating in
scotland omicron has now firmly
established itself as the dominant
strain we know from the estrogen dropout
indicator that it now accounts for 62.9
percent of all cases that's compared to
27.5 percent this time last week omicron
is significantly more transmissible than
previous variants and we estimate it our
number is well above three
it is currently spreading rapidly across
scotland and so the steep increase in
infections that was predicted last week
has now started to materialize casey's
increased by more than 50 percent in the
past week from over 3 500 a day on
average to almost 5 500 a day
there were increases across all age
groups but the biggest an increase of
161 percent was in the 20 to 24 year old
age group
the rate of acceleration in an age
cohort with to date lower levels
relatively speaking of booster
protection underlines the vital
importance of everyone getting booster
jags as quickly as possible and i'll
return to that later
however as the booster rollout is
completed and bearing in mind that it
takes around a week for immune
protection to take effect in individuals
we must also act to slow down the spread
of cases and i want to explain why that
is so vital firstly the toll that a
rising wave of infections will have on
health and on health and social care is
considerable we don't yet know if the
proportion of omicron cases needing
hospital care will be lower higher or
the same as with delta however there's
still no compelling evidence that
omicron is intrinsically milder than
previous strains
however even if the proportion of cases
needing hospital care is lower as we
hope it will be a smaller proportion of
a much larger number of infections will
still have a deeply damaging impact
as well as the suffering cause to
individuals and families the additional
pressure on our already stretched
national health service will be
extremely difficult to manage
in addition to that if large numbers of
people become infected even mildly the
impact on the economy and critical
services through sickness and isolation
absences will be crippling
indeed we're already starting to see
this impact 100 scot rail services were
cancelled yesterday due to staff absence
theaters are already being forced to
cancel shows due to covert cases amongst
caste and crews and even more seriously
staffing shortages are already being
felt across the supply chain and they
are exacerbating the intense pressures
that the nhs and emergency services are
working under so this is why we must act
and let me be clear again this is not a
choice between protecting health and
protecting the economy if we don't stem
the spread of the virus both health and
the economy will suffer
now before i set out the action we must
take let me address one further point
some ask why we can't wait until we have
more data and know exactly the impact
omicron will have on the nhs i totally
understand the temptation to delay to
hope after two long years of this that
further steps might not be necessary but
firstly as i said a moment ago we are
already seeing a significant impact from
staff absences across the economy and
public services we must do what we can
to stem this and secondly we know from
experience that if we wait until the
data tells us conclusively that we have
a problem for example with hospital
admissions it will already be too late
to act to avoid that problem
we must act quickly insofar as we are
able given our financial constraints and
we must get ahead of the data if we can
so the obligation of government is to
take difficult decisions to keep the
country as safe as possible no matter
how unpopular these decisions might be
so let me now set out the steps we all
need to take
firstly though let me stress we are not
changing the advice for christmas that i
set out last week it is important that
with just a few days to go there is
certainty about family gatherings on
christmas day and boxing day i am not
asking anyone to change these however
and i can't stress this enough please do
follow advice to keep family
celebrations as safe as possible keep
gatherings as small as your family
circumstances allow make sure everyone
does a test shortly before getting
together anyone who tests positive
should not mix with others and given how
infectious omicron is you should assume
that if one member of a household is
positive the others are likely to be so
too follow hygiene advice and keep
windows open and crucially between now
and christmas day cut your contacts with
people in other households as much as
possible minimize socializing with
others either at home or in indoor
public places indeed stay at home as
much as is feasible this is the best way
of avoiding getting covered and having
to isolate over christmas or
inadvertently spreading infection when
you do meet up with others i'm really
grateful to everyone who has followed
this advice over the last week it will
be making a difference and i want to
stress this point the steep increase in
cases over the past week would have been
steeper still but for people complying
with this advice so i hope we may
already be collectively slowing the
spread but it is important that we stick
with it
so my first new request of everyone
today is this from the 27th of december
as we come out of the christmas weekend
and at least until the end of the first
week in january when we will review this
advice again please go back to limiting
your contacts as much as you possibly
can please stay at home as much as is
feasible when you do go out maintain
physical distancing from people not in
your own group
and difficult though is please follow
this advice over new year minimize hug
money socializing as much as you can if
we all follow the advice to minimise the
contact we have outside our own
households we will help limit the spread
of infections so this is the bedrock of
our plan for the immediate period ahead
however while our core advice is to
reduce socializing and stay at home as
much as feasible
the cabinet's judgment is that we must
also take some further steps to make the
places where people might still gather
as safe as possible and that is why we
are proposing some additional
protections
none of these are being proposed lightly
but we do consider them necessary to
help stem the increasing cases safeguard
health and protect the nhs the emergency
services and the economy where we
complete and get the full effect of the
booster program
so first from the 26th of december
inclusive of that date for a period of
up to three weeks we intend to place
limits on the size of live public events
that can take place
this does not apply let me stress to
private life events such as weddings
for indoor standing events the limit
will be 100 for indoor seated events it
will be 200 and for outdoor events at
500 seated or standing physical
distancing of one meter will be required
at events that go ahead within these
limits
this will of course make sports matches
including football effectively
spectator-free over this three-week
period a situation similar to that in
wales from boxing day and it will also
mean unfortunately that large scale hug
money celebrations including that
planned here in our capital city will
not proceed i know how disappointing
this will be for those looking forward
to these events and for the organizers
of them but i want to underline why we
think this difficult decision is
necessary firstly we know that the much
higher transmissibility of omicron means
large gatherings have the potential to
become very rapid super spreader events
putting large numbers at risk of getting
infected very quickly limiting these
events helps reduce the risk of
widespread transmission it also cuts
down the transmission risks associated
with travel to and from such events
and second
and this is not an insignificant point
these large events put an additional
burden on emergency services especially
the police and ambulance services at a
time when these services are already
under severe pressure and also dealing
with high staff absences limiting
large-scale events will help them focus
on delivering essential services to the
public so i would ask the public despite
the disappointment i know this decision
will generate to please understand the
reasons for it
second we intend to issue guidance to
the effect that non-professional indoor
contact sports for adults should not
take place at during up to a three week
period from 26 december this is because
these activities where physical
distancing is not possible also create a
heightened risk of transmission and
finally from the 27th of december again
for up to three weeks we intend to
introduce some further protections in
hospitality settings and other indoor
public places to reduce transmission
risk in what are through no fault of
those who run such venues higher risk
environments i can confirm that a
requirement for table service only will
be reintroduced for venues serving
alcohol for consumption on the premises
and we will also ask indoor hospitality
and leisure venues to ensure one metre
distance not within but between groups
of people who are attending together and
we will continue to advise as i set out
last week people that if they are
attending indoor hospitality or leisure
venues and remember our code advice
remains to minimize this there should be
no more than three households
represented in any group
playing officer i know how unwelcome
this will be for everyone but we believe
these precautionary steps will help us
navigate a difficult period more safely
i'm also acutely aware that these
decisions and the advice we are giving
the public have significant financial
implications for many businesses
last week i announced 100 million pounds
of support from within our existing
resources for affected sectors i can
also confirm eligibility and guidance
for the hospitality sector will be
published on the scottish government
website today since then the treasury
has given approval for money that would
have come to us later to be allocated
now
as i have said we had already budgeted
for most of that money and so we cannot
allocate it now without causing
significant shortfalls elsewhere
including in the health budget that
money simply cannot be spent twice
however we estimate that the treasury
announcements do give us additional
spending power now of 175 million pounds
and i can confirm today that we will
allocate all of this to business support
the treasury has also in the last hour
or so announced additional funding for
business unfortunately it would appear
that this announcement generates no
further funding for scotland and that
any consequentials are already contained
within previous announcements by the
treasury i can however announce that the
scottish government will allocate a
further 100 million pounds from
elsewhere in our budget between now and
the end of the financial year this will
involve really difficult decisions but
the impact of the current crisis on
business is such that we consider it
essential so taken together this adds up
to a fund of 375 million pounds that
will help support businesses for the
unavoidable impacts of our decisions
over the next three weeks this is
significantly more proportionately than
the chancellor has just announced for
businesses elsewhere in the uk
exciting officer while this is
significant funding i understand that it
will not fully compensate business as i
said last week my view is that the scale
and urgency of the omicron challenge
requires financial support for business
on a scale similar to that at the start
of the pandemic however current uk
funding arrangements mean firstly that
only the treasury has the borrowing
powers to provide support on such a
scale and second that financial support
at scale is triggered only when the uk
government takes decisions for england
all of this means that our ability to
act to protect public health and to
compensate individuals and businesses
affected is curtailed
this cannot be right in a public health
emergency
so while today's treasury announcement
may be a welcome acknowledgement of the
crisis businesses face it does not yet
go far enough we will therefore continue
to press the uk government to take the
threat of omicron more seriously and to
act accordingly but in the meantime we
will indeed we must live up to our own
responsibilities to do everything we can
to protect health lives and livelihoods
here in scotland
exciting officer before i conclude with
an update on vaccination let me cover
two further points
firstly it remains our priority i hope
parliament's priority to reopen schools
as normal after the christmas holidays
indeed one reason for asking adults to
make sacrifices for a further period
after christmas is to help minimise any
impact on children's education however
to help ensure that schools are safe
environments for young people and staff
updated guidance based on
recommendations from the education
advisory subgroup it was published at
the end of last week colleges and
universities are also assessing any
steps they need to take for the new term
and some are returning to a default
model of online learning for the start
of the new term
for everyone involved in education staff
children students and parents this has
been another exceptionally difficult
term and i want to say a heartfelt thank
you to all those who have helped ensure
that children have been well supported
and indeed to children and young people
themselves for the tough times that they
continue to endure at such an important
stage of their lives
second point i want to cover briefly
relates to test and protect the current
surgeon cases is putting significant
pressure on test and protect and i'm
grateful to all of its teams for working
so hard to help break chains of
transmission from this week test and
protect will flex its approach as
necessary to ensure priority is given to
higher risk settings such as hospitals
and care homes where outbreaks can cause
most harm for many of us this means that
if we test positive our contact from
test and protect teams is more likely to
be by text or email rather than phone
call please make sure you respond to
these messages and complete the online
form that is sent this helps your
contacts get the right advice as quickly
as possible and if you are the contact
of someone who tests positive please
follow test and protect advice this will
help slow the spread of the virus
let me turn finally to booster jags
which are of course our best line of
defense against omicron and the airport
will get us through and out of this
difficult phase i believe
there has been a significant
acceleration of the programme in the
past week and i thank everyone involved
a further two large-scale vaccination
centres have opened this week at hampden
in glasgow and at the edinburgh
international conference centre
yesterday 69
135 boosters or third doses were
administered that means well over half
now of the adult population has had a
third dose or a booster
last week i said that our target was to
have 80
of the eligible population vaccinated
with boosters by the time the bell
strike on hug money i can confirm today
that we are now confident we have the
capacity to meet that target but of
course to reach it or get as close to it
as possible we need everyone who is
eligible to come forward
so if you have an appointment booked for
january please now reschedule it for
december appointments will be available
right through christmas eve and then
next week up to and including hug money
so please book an appointment now
alternatively check out the location of
drop-in clinics and go there instead
getting fully vaccinated is the best
thing any of us can do to protect
ourselves our loved ones and the country
so please do get boosted before the
bells
signing officer this statement in some
ways feels distressingly similar to the
one i gave this time last year
just a few days before christmas i'm
again urging people to stay at home as
much as possible to slow down a highly
infectious new variant of covet
but although it might not feel like it
we are in a much stronger position than
last year we have had far fewer
restrictions in place for much of this
year than was the case in the previous
year christmas day this year will be
more normal than last year
most importantly of all a rapidly
increasing number of adults is now
protected by three doses of vaccine
and all of us as individuals know what
to do to protect ourselves and each
other so please make sure you do all of
these things first get fully vaccinated
as soon as possible second test
regularly our advice of course is to
stay at home as much as possible but if
you are meeting other people test before
you go every time
and test as close to going as possible
and this is really important of course
for family gatherings on christmas day
or boxing day and finally take all the
other precautions which can help to make
a difference work from home when
possible stay at home as much as you can
if you do visit indoor public places
limit the number of households in your
group to a maximum of three we have face
covering on public transport in shops
and we're moving about in hospitality
and make sure the covering fully covers
your mouth and nose keep windows open if
you're meeting indoors even at this time
of year and follow all advice on hygiene
sticking to all of this is really hard
but there is no doubt whatsoever it will
help keep all of us safer
so i want to end this final statement
before christmas presiding officer with
a heartfelt thank you to everyone for
everything you have done to help us
through another exceptionally tough year
i wish everyone the happiest and safest
christmas possible and of course a much
better and brighter new year ahead